and i'm joined tonight by kate andrews
and nigel nelson good evening to you
both welcome
uh let's start with the
guardian uh front page um
and uh just really distressing i mean
that's the only word i can come up with
the horror that is unfolding
in butcher nigel
yeah i mean it really is it's absolutely
horrific i mean what we're seeing now
is because you uh ukraine the ukrainian
army is now retaking ground
particularly in butcher and urban
you begin to see the actual horrors that
the
russian forces have committed
and so i mean we've got you know
pictures on the front page you've been
showing them on on sky news um you've
blacked out some of the the bodies lying
in the streets actually you can see them
on the front pages
ukrainian army going in and having to
swerve around them as these bodies are
lying in the street
question obviously is now what could be
done about it after the event will we be
able to actually get those who are
responsible for this before a war crimes
trial or indeed
boris johnson's aim of trying to get
putin to the hague to face charges
yes and ukraine's president um saying
that the kremlin ordered this attack on
his country and it's a deliberate attack
on civilians i mean that's as clear as
day isn't it kate
it is indeed for weeks now we've seen
the videos of the bombing and shelling
of parts of ukraine
we know that people have been injured
people have been dying from the
aggression that russia has taken against
ukraine what we're seeing now though as
ukraine takes back these territories uh
and many of them are around the capital
kiev uh is that the russian soldiers
have been committing barbaric acts
against individuals as well
nothing to do with military strategy
there are now
reports and increasing evidence of
torture of rape they're starting to find
mass graves and they're starting to find
evidence that this is deliberately
attempted to be covered up the burning
of bodies uh which all fits with what we
would understand to be deliberate war
crimes it's utterly horrendous it's
extremely difficult to look at these uh
photos of men women and children um who
have have been tortured and killed um
one of the interesting elements of this
of course is that
at the very start of russia's war people
thought it would be a matter of days
before putin took heave it's been well
over a month and now ukrainians are
taking back territory around the capital
this is strategically from a military
perspective very bad news for russia
but we are discovering what the soldiers
have been doing there and
it is truly barbaric towards the
ukrainian people yes it is uh and
ukraine's military released footage uh
yesterday of what appeared to be a
torture chamber in a basement
um with a barracks in an adjoining room
a line of bodies was found hands tied
and crouched facing a wall
um
nigel you mentioned
boris johnson saying that he wanted to
take vladimir putin to to the hague
that surely has to be the the only
end result of all of this doesn't it
yeah but i mean the whole thing is to
make that the end result it will mean
that putin will no longer be president
of russia
i can't see any other way that you could
actually get him before a war crimes
trial
unless there was there was a new regime
in russia
that really isn't a matter for us i mean
um uh president biden has had to roll
back on the idea that the that this is
all about regime change in moscow
so the question really is what putin
does next that uh in a sense the biggest
danger of all i think now is that he
can't really fail in ukraine um and so
there's there's always the risk of worse
weapons being used possibly chemical or
biological
to try and win this war
that it may be that we'll we'll get
something out of peace talks especially
if president zielenski uh and putin can
actually sit down together
but we but it's difficult to see quite
how the how the end game works without
uh in actually going but that's a matter
for the intelligence services in russia
and the generals who have the power
yes we move on to the metro and they're
describing the atrocities uh committed
on the people of ukraine as worse than
than those uh committed by isis worse
than isis is the headline
kate
so part of the problem here is that the
further putin takes his aggressive acts
and the worse that the russian military
acts towards individuals in ukraine the
harder it is to come to the table and to
go to those peace talks uh and the
harder it is to provide putin an
off-ramp uh which could uh bring you
know some kind of stability uh back to
the region uh because the more that we
discover the more difficult it is to
negotiate with somebody who's committed
these absolutely atrocious acts and
this kind of leads into the ft story now
we're about to talk about but it also
makes it more difficult to imagine us
going back to any kind of neutral or
remotely friendly relationship with
russia as long as vladimir putin remains
its dictator
because of these acts because of what
he's done
even if let's say you know we can only
pray that overnight russia were to
decide that it's made a huge error and
completely retreat out of ukraine i
still don't see a circumstance now in
which the west turns around and says
actually importing russian gas is
absolutely fine we're going to lift all
these economic sanctions we're not going
to worry about the oligarchs anymore i
think we are now in completely different
territory the world is going to be set
differently from now on and as long as
putin is in charge of russia most of the
west i suspect will not be able to act
normally towards that country again
and nigel despite uh all the evidence of
the pictures that the footage um most of
it too too graphic to be shown russia is
dismissing this as being staged
well i mean we've got an independent
witnesses that this is actually
happening i mean this is not just
a claim by the ukrainians
reporters have been going going uh in
there they've been arriving hours after
the ukrainian army did and they've seen
it with their own eyes and you've got
the pictures on sky news
so what we that we now have is is this
is not just a claim we have proper
evidence of genocide of war crimes uh
and that's that's thanks to western
media being there
so i don't think that now there can be
any doubt that these atrocities are
being committed
well we move on to the financial times
as you mentioned uh cater and this is
really the the economic war waged
against russia the call for for full
sanctions the calls for full oil and gas
embargo that being the only way that you
can really uh dent uh putin's um
attempts really to to take over in in
ukraine
well having decisively decided not to
put boots on the ground the west is
contributing through funding to ukraine
supplying military uh supplies uh
weapons but specifically with economic
sanctions as well as you say with
genetic economic uh war in solidarity
with ukraine but i think this is where
we're going to see the increasing
tension between mustard countries
because so far that unity well it was a
bit wobbly at the beginning has been
very strong but let's not forget we have
not completely cut off russian energy
supplies to europe you know the gas is
still flowing because it would be
extremely painful near impossible for
certain countries like germany to
overnight cut off those supplies but now
you have countries like poland and the
baltics that are reporting to be pushing
countries like germany and france and
the uk and the us to go even tougher on
economic sanctions they really want to
hike tariffs on energy and it will be
interesting to see how this plays out
because
these photos and images that we're now
getting of the deliberate torture and
rape and murder of ukrainians committed
by the russian military is going to make
it very difficult for any political
leader in the west to suggest it's not
time to go further but the sanctions
that were already being discussed were
around closing loopholes bringing in
more individual sanctions against
oligarchs tightening up the central bank
restrictions and you've got countries
like poland and baltic saying no no we
need to go further we really need to cut
off that russian energy we really need
to get them where we know it's going to
hurt that is going to be a debate uh
with with uh with the western european
countries who are so heavily dependent
on that energy at a time where the cost
of leaving living squeeze is already
being felt acutely and is only set to
get worse
uh nigel do you think we've got to the
point where the
international community does have to to
take some of the pain to to actually
make a difference the sanctions so far
haven't stopped putin do we have to take
some of the pain in order for them to be
effective
yes i think we do
um i mean it is the only way we all have
to pay a price for this
it's not just us as individuals it's got
to be governments it's got to be
businesses uh businesses might start
thinking about uh getting their workers
a little bit more because of the extra
cost of all this in wages and i think
what was interesting on the financial
times report is even uh italy or there
are calls in italy for a total embargo
on russian oil gas and coal
now which is one of the european
countries which depends hugely on
russian gas but i think there's a kind
of mood now amongst european leaders
they've got to get together they've got
to really make the sanctions bite and
it's in the energy sector where that
would actually work
now i was going to say um that uh this
story is uh back on the agenda but it's
never really gone away has it partygate
and the times is looking at um the fines
that are to be handed out kate take us
into this
so this is the first set of fines that
are being issued by the met police uh to
downing street staff who took who we now
know took part in a party evening before
prince philip's funeral and as you say
this isn't a story that's ever gone away
but obviously the headlines have been
dominated um by extremely serious
matters recently and it's an important
reminder that while the prime minister
is not thought to have been issued a
fine yet because downing street said
that they will inform us if he is
his comments about what was happening in
number 10 when are seriously under
scrutiny especially as these fines are
actually being issued it would suggest
that the met police thought there was
enough evidence um to actually dish
these out um and depending on what
happens with the headlines in ukraine
frankly i think will have a lot to do
with how much attraction the story gets
because this would have been on every
front page uh before the humanitarian
disaster that we're seeing unfolds in
ukraine uh as it happens you know it's a
small box on some of the front pages
today this is on page two of the times
it isn't getting the same kind of press
that i got before for understandable
reasons but it doesn't mean it's not
still going to be a major headache for
the pm and something there are more
questions for him to answer in the
coming months uh regardless of what else
is in the news yeah nigel whatever you
want to know is uh will the prime
minister be fined what do you think the
chances are of that
well i mean he was he was at a number of
the parties that
the police are investigating
um so the chances out of thought are
fairly high um
his great defense at the moment is that
because number 10 is both an office and
a home
he didn't actually break any rules
because he was in the office bit when he
was going to the parties um the same
thing of course may not apply to to his
wife carrie who of course can't use the
same excuse but what the times are
suggesting is that the that the prime
minister probably won't be interviewed
by the police and the reason for that is
they're just interviewing witnesses
rather than people they're thinking of
finding which means of course that boris
johnson is still in the frame for a fine
um if the police decide to do that
yes we shall wait and see and we move on
to the telegraph front page um pictured
there actually helen mcnamara who
received a 50-pound frying on a friday
um and that's after police concluding
that she she broke her coveted laws but
the story that we're looking at is
covered restrictions
and the damage that they may have caused
to the development of um of children
this is a report by ofsted kate
so whatever you think of the lockdowns
that they were too strict that they
weren't strict enough that the
government went too far that they didn't
do enough there is no doubt that we are
going to be living with the consequences
of essentially shutting society off and
then turning it back on several times
throughout the past two years for a very
very long time and this offset report is
one of those many examples but a very
concerning one it's found that the coven
restrictions have left what they
describe as a generation of babies and
toddlers that are struggling to crawl
and communicate and they're behind in
these critical skills because they
didn't have the proper socialization and
they didn't go through the same
processes that they would have done in
an open society so they're finding that
children have a more limited vocabulary
some are struggling to respond to basic
facial expressions because they weren't
learning them in the way that they would
have done without the lockdowns um you
know it makes for extremely grim reading
and we're gonna see things like this not
simply for for babies and toddlers but
for students as well for young people
and what happened to the education
process during lockdown so expect more
reports like this there's a lot of
catching up to do now yes it does seem
that the the young have have suffered um
quite a bit during the the pandemic and
the article talking about the fact that
language skills have been delayed
because uh simply many of them would
have been uh communicating and looked
after people who had to wear masks the
whole time nigel
yeah that's that's right i think it's
one of the most interesting things that
things about this report um that the the
that they were actually uh being being
taught by adults wearing masks and
they've been but for their whole lives
that's what they've gone through we've
known about what's been happening in
schools and how far behind children have
been there
certainly until i saw this i hadn't
really thought about what what was going
on for early years but if you've got a
situation where with child minders
babies aren't crawling
um and that
and children can't communicate it shows
how far behind they are
so they spend so much time in front of
screens according to this report they're
even picking up the accents of people
that they were watching
so it does seem to be their development
has been been really badly skewed yes it
is it is very sad about how to to make
up for that time that they've lost is is
the question um just uh very quickly
kate as you are an economist um we're
going to look at the telegraph business
page and the price of milk uh set to
rise i was just
actually
admitting that i don't know what the the
cost of a pint of milk is but then
that's my excuse is because we don't get
them in pints anymore
kate do you know
well i i live an apartment on my own so
i get the baby ones and which are best
the cost of those are going up too and
i'm not an economist i just write about
it but thank you for over promoting me
this is actually a very concerning story
because uh you know that
if we weren't talking about ukraine
right now again we'll be talking about
partygate and the cost of living crisis
everybody in the country but especially
those at the lower end of the spectrum
is feeling that squeeze and for
something like you know a critical
essential good like milk to be going up
an estimated 50
because of the shortage that the dairy
market is experiencing um it is going to
be felt by everybody and it's just one
of countless examples of what happens
when you have surging inflation which we
now have in the uk which we have not
managed to get under control and is
certainly not transitory as central
bankers are were once saying it's
something we're going to be living with
for some time um and it does it going to
mean difficult choices and that means
difficult political choices too